so your debut novel the 13th continuum
sold and then at some point you have now
a three-book deal which is that was the
first book of the three and now it's
being turned into a film yeah we're
working on that so my background is that
I used to work in film and TV
development and so actually before I
even sold it to a publisher
I had producers that were working on it
it's always had a lot of interest from a
lot of producers the first set of
producers wants to do it for TV and
we're sort of working with them but a
certain point they weren't being super
effective and we kind of felt more like
going in the film direction so I
switched to a different producer and
she's been great and we're working on
packaging it into a film so they have a
deal at Warner Brothers and then right
now we're looking at writers and
directors because in the environment of
right now it really helps to have a
package and to go in with a package and
there are a couple of reasons why I
think that's good but one of them is
that I don't want to rush and do a bad
version of the film I've worked enough
in Hollywood and worked on enough big
book adaptations like Lord of the Rings
and The Golden Compass that I know it
really matters how you put it together
and then also it's one thing just to
option a book you can do that but then
there's something we call development
Hell where it just kind of gets stuck
and never it gets made so the more you
have attached and the more you go in
with the more likely it is that you're
going to actually be able to make the
film because I don't want to just option
it and have it sit and there are so many
fabulous books and fabulously popular
books that have never been made that
sold for a lot of money that studios
have things like Justin Kernan's the
passage is a good example and it just
hasn't been made it's been years and
years so I kind of want to do it in a
way that really does justice so I'm not
really in a rush I want to do it right
well so the second book is coming out
November 1st yes and tell me the title
it's called return of the continuance
okay and then you have the third book
which you're finishing up now as we
speak I'm finishing it up now and that
will come out in probably end of May
next year and it's called the United
Continuum's so that's the other thing
that's nice about a series is that with
each book is an operator
and really kind of drives attention and
drives readership and there's a whole
marketing effort so it's kind of nice
because you know you don't have one book
and that kind of gets forgotten you're
left behind each time you're going out
with a new book it's bringing them all
kind of together and you see a lot of
times these things build over time
readership builds popularity builds and
we can all cite really famous series
where they weren't big until later
there's a great piece by the author he
wrote Percy Jackson that series which
were made into films and I think he said
it was two full years after the first
book came out was when they first had an
inkling that it was going to be a huge
huge hit but for two years it wasn't
selling much and they weren't sure he
was doing signings like nobody was
showing up but it was a building process
like they really believed in it and they
really worked hard so it can take time
and the other thing to remember with a
book and I'm sort of experiencing this
now is that it's not like a film where
you know everyone will go opening day
and see it and then be talking to their
friends like you know even if people buy
it close to when it comes out it might
not get read instantly a lot of us and
this includes me have a ton of books in
our queue and a lot of things it doesn't
mean we're not going to read it but it
might be a month or two later that I
finally do and so you start to see that
even a couple months after it's been out
people are finally like oh my gosh I
finally read this and you start to hear
and I'll send more people you start to
hear so it's like not like an opening
day phenomenon and the other cool thing
about books as they exist and once
they're in the world they're in the
world a long time so you started to see
them popping up in libraries and popping
up that's the nice thing about young
adult is that you know libraries are
huge for us schools are huge for us
school libraries are huge for us
and there's also a lot of kids that
can't really afford or don't have the
budgets to buy a lot of books so they're
waiting to get them from their library
which i think is fantastic I was that
kid so I totally understand that
you